so many iconic films that you've made
deliverance is a movie that I've always
wanted to talk to you about because one
of my favorite all-time film I'm curious
do you think that deliverance could be
made today there's something to me about
that film that it feels like it could
only have been made during that period
in the 70s it would be I think you're
right I know that those guys that we had
I you know John Boorman who was an Irish
director the best director I've had said
where am I gonna find these guys these
are the guys to play though the the hill
people Mountain they're not met yeah and
I said I know a guy
he can't read and he can't write or
anything but he I'm telling you if we
can get him we got something special so
I said let me bring him in his name is
cowboy and he'll just talk to you and
you see if you like him so he came in
and they're just even everything and he
said up did you tell but I can't breathe
I said yes I told that and the director
but just read this first line here
cowboy and he went and he looked over at
me I'm gonna get this beat out of me no
and he and he said well the first a lot
up the first line cowboy is get over
against that tree and take your pants
down and he said get over against that
sapling and take your panties down
and the director said you got the part
[Laughter]
so we we start just with that scene
which scene what scene particularly we
talking about that the the scene where
he says you've got a mighty pretty mouth
yeah yeah in deliverance idiot yeah yeah
and you thought that scene would end
your career
pop attack I thought it was gonna be
close I mean you know you can't those
kind of pictures are because I hadn't
done anything like that nobody nobody
had made that I mean I still I look at
that movie and I look at the the acting
that Ned Beatty did in that film should
have been nominated it's it's um one of
the most amazing scenes it's one of the
most and I've watched that movie so many
times and one of the things I love so
much about it is some of the ambiguity
and some of the ambiguity about human
emotion in that film is so absolutely
right absolutely right and also that the
fact that those two guys cowboy and the
other gentleman who was a Hollywood
actor but cowboy was from right from
there and he i said cowboy whatever you
want to say just say it you know they'll
cut it out they don't like it well he he
just started dad living up a storm and
they kept every word he said because
gold yeah yeah that that particular line
I mean I'll be driving sometimes at a
car and a guy will pull up beside me and
say you've got a mighty pretty mouth
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you